Theo các bạn thông sò của CNN, ZOS, SOS, S3,
thông điều lưỡi bàn gà mang nhìn không trai bị sống của tổn thống Mỹ đường đơn trang.
Đánh nhận đường đánh giá nghiên trung là tích cục từ nhóm khán giả thảo gió chửi tiếp.
Trong đỏ 1,2 phần bà truyết có phản nướng tích cục hoặc giết tích cục,
tuy nhiên mức độ một hộ này thấp hơn sau với một số bài phát biểu trúc đây,
và chưa thuy phục hoàn toàn khán giả về việc tập trung và các vấn đề quan trọng
đặc biệt như là Chee Phi Sinh Hoa.
Họ giá cho thấy tỉ lệ người tin rằng các chính xác của thông thống trang sẽ đưa đông Mỹ để đủ hướng
tăng tự năng mi tư phần trang chức bài phần biểu,
lên sống mi tư phần trang xau bài phần biểu.
Sống mức độ tình tượng và phản nâng kiểm soát chỉ Phi Sinh Hoa,
vẫn còn hạn chế khi có tập bối mấy phần trang không tình tượng.
Cây kiến cũng chương sế về cách sửy bản đề thử quan và nhập cơ.
Phản nướng chính trẻ công xin xác trái chè chè chè chè chè chè chè chè chè chè chè chè chè chè chè.
Và đưa ra pháp biểu phản hội chỉ chỉ cái chính xác của chính quyền.
Rồi phân tinh nhận định, các bạn phát biểu chức hồ í thường cùng của quân điểm sánh có cuộc khán sản.
Hôm làm phạm xác phay đổi lần trước mức độ hội chung của công chống.